Surveys are one of the easiest ways to get info on a population. Sometimes it is
really difficult to conduct the survey, but surveys are often a lot easier than
doing, say, a controlled experiment. They're also relatively inexpensive. They
mostly just require time to implement, and for the respondents to write their
answers. Surveys can also be conducted remotely. You might have gotten a survey
in the mail at one point. And finally, this is my favorite thing about surveys.
Anyone can access and analyze survey results if the survey owner is willing to
give out that data. But assuming they are, the survey results are timeless. The
National Center for Education Statistics created this Education Longitudinal
Study and thanks to them, I was able to look at factors that influence effort
including how much students enjoy school, or how much students value school, or
their relationship with their teachers, their gender, and a bunch of other
things. it was really fun and interesting to analyze this data. Looking at
someone else's survey results can be a lot easier than conducting your own
survey.